and a man accused of sexually
trafficking a minor is now in custody
yeah we're talking about brandon range
facing five charges including sex
trafficking of a child kidnapping as
well as child abuse mary jane bellezza
has more with how this teen helped put
police in front of behind bars
police received a tip from the national
center for missing and exploited
children about a sexual assault victim
it only took three days for officers to
find who they were looking for and
arrest him as they continue to work to
stop trafficking on the strip in an
arrest report obtained by 8 news now
25-year-old brandon range is accused of
trafficking a young person through a
well-known prostitution website
undercover police contacted the victim
and agreed to meet at a target on
maryland parkway and flamingo the victim
told police she ran away from home
police say the victim was involved in a
prostitution ring for several years and
at range in california last week
investigators say undercover officers
reached out to range posing as a
prostitute the next day detectives
learned range would be at valleys where
an undercover operation took place range
reportedly telling an undercover officer
that he would assist her as a prostitute
and provide her with transportation
housing and drugs shortly after the
meetup police took range into custody
they also found a gun and drugs on him
range remains in jail tonight police say
he's also a fugitive out of l.a he's
expected back in court next month with
those charges here if you or someone you
know is in a similar situation you can
contact metro or the fbi reporting from
the strip mary jane balleza live local
now